après 24 heures de garde à vue le
chauffeur de car a commencé à parler des
aveux partiels sur certaines
disparitions de jeunes filles près
d'auxerre entre 1977 et 1979
elle était cette handicapée mentale et
fréquenté le même établissement
spécialisé
emile louis chauffeur du car les
connaissais tout car il n'est conduisait
chaque jour à l'école
un chauffeur que les familles des
disparus ont rapidement suspecté
le chauffeur du coeur on le dit depuis
le début
tout tourne autour de lui nous avons des
disparus qui n'ont vu pour la dernière
fois il les a conduites à la gare par
exemple qu'après le disparaissent tout
comme dans la fumée s'est il est évident
que cet homme là pour nous représente la
fourche véritable de cette vérité que
nous recherchons
déjà en 1981 et 1008 soupçonné du
meurtre venant 10 capes et faute de
preuves il est relâché
en 1997 il avait accepté de nous
rencontrer
il n'y est alors toute implication dans
la sphère des disparues de l'yonne
vous avez besoin d'être un bouc
émissaire aujourd'hui oui oui les gens
cherchent un petit roi et que je suis
absolument pour rien j'ai toujours mais
aujourd'hui devant les enquêteurs il a
dû s'expliquer sur un nouvel élément la
découverte ici à son domicile d'une
malle remplie de vêtements de jeunes
filles des vêtements reconnu
formellement par certains parents des
disparus
des tests adn ont également été
effectués c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que les gardes à vue vient d'être
prolongée de 24 heures